en el día del mar el presidente de
Bolivia Luis Arce ha planteado a Chile
el inicio de una nueva etapa con un
diálogo que incluya siete puntos entre
ellos la demanda marítima boliviana las
aguas del silala el litio además de
temas migratorios y fronterizos hay que
recordar que Bolivia no tiene acceso
soberano al mar desde el año 1879 lo ha
perdido a través de una guerra con chile
el presidente Luis Arce ha señalado sin
embargo que este tema es una herida en
América Latina y ha dicho que la
reivindicación es irrenunciable hay que
recordar que durante la última década
tanto Bolivia como chile se han
sumergido en un litigio internacional
ante la Corte Internacional de Justicia
de la haya Bolivia ha demandado a chile
y ha pedido que la corte le obligue a
negociar con Bolivia este acceso
soberano al mar la corte ha señalado que
chile no tiene obligación de negociar
con Bolivia sin embargo el presidente
Luis Arce considera que hay un punto en
ese fallo que que el tema está pendiente
y que tanto chile como Bolivia tendrían
que continuar negociando y en ese Marco
es que ha planteado esta agenda de siete
puntos al gobierno chileno durante esta
jornada se han realizado una serie de
actos conmemorativos en Bolivia entre
ellos desfiles ofrendas florales así
como actos políticos y militares el
expresidente Evo Morales quien ha sido
el que ha demandado a Chile hace una
década por el acceso soberano al mar ha
dicho que esta reivindicación es
irrenunciable en Bolivia